You've gone through a lot by this point,
you've written an application with
separation of concerns in mind and
you've also added a completely
unexpected feature to it.
That is nothing to sneeze at,
that's impressive.
Now rock-star developers will often
write code entirely in JavaScript
with no organizational libraries,
and that's what we just did so
seriously give yourself a pat
on the back, it's impressive.
Sometimes though, it is useful to
use an organizational framework or
a library to give you
the features you need,
without needing to do a ton
of work at the beginning.
We'll learn how to use one of them,
and what they name their octopus.
So, keep going, keep the momentum up,
you're doing great, and
there's some really fun stuff coming up.